match à enjeu à plaisir le club local
recevait carrière grésillons demi-finale
de la coupe des yvelines après une
première période rythmée ce sont
finalement les visiteurs qui ouvrent le
score sur un pénalty 1 à 0 ce sera le
score à la mi temps c'est une par une
première période très pas très disputé
forcément une demi-finale tout le monde
a envie de jouer la finale ça assez
équilibré on voit que carrière c'est une
équipe solide et qui auront réussi à
ouvrir le score sur un penalty un peu un
coup du sort c'est le jeu on a toujours
espoir on a il ya de la place pour aller
gagner ce match on est deux équipes de
la même division et on se connaît on est
capable d'aller les patrons malgré une
domination plaisir oise en seconde
période les joueurs n'arrivent pas à
conclure et concède un second penalty
sur cette action et je ne reviendront
pas dans la partie score final 2 à 0
très déçu très déçu après c'est le
football hand on va commencer par
féliciter carrière baca qui a mérité sa
qualification qu'en se qualifiant le
mérite donc bravo à eux d'abord on a mis
les ingrédients pour gagner ce match on
a quarante cinq premières minutes qui
était à peu près équilibrées on prend un
premier but sur un petit détail presse
on reste quand même dans le match prouve
que la deuxième mi temps on a totalement
dominé l'adversaire on avait pas mal
d'occasions nettes on a touché la barre
le gardien aussi il était sur quelques
points on n'a vraiment pas de chance
pour plaisir il faudrait espérer un peu
plus de chance l'année prochaine pour
soulever la coupe de son côté carrière
grésillons rencontrera le club de vélizy
en finale de la coupe des yvelines
le 16 juin à verneuil sur seine